un d'effroi ça sert à faire sonner la
cloche la cloche communal pas la cloche
de l'église
c'est con façade qui est travaillé en
dentelle le premier renaissance c'est à
dire qu'on retrouve tout le répertoire
ornementale il suit des premiers
échanges entre architecte et décorateur
français et italiens dreux est peut-être
le plus au sud
db froid du nord c'est-à-dire des
beffrois cossu il existe sous cette
forme là parce que c'est une ville
économiquement dynamique à la
renaissance
[Musique]
c'est dans cette salle que se réunissait
le conseil mais c'est aussi dans cette
salle qu'on rendait la justice royale et
on montre ici
et bien justement cette interdépendance
qu'il ya entre le suzerain et son
brassard c'est à dire entre le compte de
dreux et l'habitant de la ville 1 c'est
un édifice de transition architecturale
entre le gothique flamboyant donc la fin
du xvème siècle et le début du xvième
siècle la première renaissance française
et ça on peut le voir particulièrement
dans une voûte de nervures qui se
rejoignent au niveau d'une clé plan
dante et qui forment comme une fleur qui
est clos
toute l'élégance de ce beffroi
j'irai rassemblés dans cette colonne
torse finalisée sous forme de roue de
nervures c'est un élément qui est
presque inédit dans notre région
cette cloche là a été refondue en 1839
parce que la cloche originale de 15 161
s'est brisé on a décidé de la refondre à
l'identique et pour cela on à réaliser
un moulage de la cloche original dreux
est une ville complètement intemporel
giret et qu'il vit vraiment au rythme de
ses cloches comme on le faisait à la
renaissance et je pense qu'on peut pas
oublier leur dans cette ville
[Musique]